est ce que toutes les femmes ont envie
de se faire violer je pense oui
sincèrement oui si je vous disais que
moi je bats ma femme me soit plus
gentille est plus amoureuse de moi
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu envie de
violer une femme oui d'une certaine
façon
[Musique]
bonjour nous allons aujourd'hui parler
des femmes battues un sujet dont la
presse fait largement écho depuis
quelques semaines décidé de le quitter
après l'avoir violée il était presque
gentil avec moi il essayait de dire sa
vie sentimentale malheureuse de misère
tout ça et je voulais pas l'entendre
mais c'est évident que ça le
déculpabiliser
comme s'il n'avait pas violé violeur
pour jamais qui viole on connaît le
verdict six ans et deux fois quatre ans
de réclusion criminelle pour les
violeurs en fait c'est un procès qui
s'est très vite transformé en procès du
viol tout court
[Musique]
il ne peut pas y avoir de société où le
couple au plan de l'amour soit basée sur
un rapport de force physique je dis que
c'est quasiment du fascisme
[Musique]